مقتل اكثر من 300 شخص في السودان مع دخول
الاشتباكات يومها الخامس ومسؤولون يكشفون
عن مصير الجنود المصريين المحتجزين وعدد
سكان الهند يتجاوز الصين بحلول منتصف
العام الجاري هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا متابعينا من السودان فمع دخول
المعارك بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
يومها الخامس اعلنت الامم المتحده تجاوز
عدد القتلى 300 قتيل واكثر من 2600 جريح
حتى الان جاء ذلك في وقت تبادل طرفان نزاع
الاتهامات بشان خرق الهدنه فالناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني قال ان قوات الدعم السريع
هي من انتهكت هدنه وقف اطلاق النار مضيفا
ان الجيش تمكن من التصدي لهجوم جديد على
محيط القياده العامه من جهتها اتهمت الدعم
السريع الجيش في كسر الهدنه المعلنه
واضافت ان الجيش مستمر في شن هجمات باسلحه
ثقيله على مواقع تمركزها
نحو خمس سكان كوكب الارض تقترب الهند من
تجاوز الصين بعدد السكان حيث اظهرت بيانات
اصدرتها الامم المتحده ان الهند في طريقها
لتصبح اكبر دوله في العالم من حيث عدد
السكان متجاوزه الصين بنحو ثلاثه ملايين
شخص في منتصف هذا العام حيث سيبلغ عدد
سكان الهند مليار و428 مليونا بالرغم من
تراجع النمو السكاني للدولتين الاسيويتين
العملاقتين فيما تاتي الولايات المتحده
بالمركز الثالث وبفارق كبير اذ يقدر عدد
سكانها بنحو 340 مليون نسمه
الاخبار الفضاء حيبقى يترقب في العالم
سقوط قمر اصطناعي متقاعد لوكاله ناسا
الامريكيه على الارض خلال الساعات المقبله
دور معرفه موقع السكوت على وجه التحديد
خبراء في مجال الفضاء قالوا ان احتمالات
الخطر الذي يشكله سقوط قمر ناصر الصناعي
منخفضه ومن المتوقع انه سيحترق عندما
يندفع للغلاف الجوي ليلى اليوم الاربعاء
ويبلغ وزن القمر الاصطناعي نحو 300 كيلو
جرام